hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
may 9th 2022
um
what's going on
how are you
oh yeah
well that's good
you don't say
i am in a [ __ ]
awesome mood
all right because
i had my head in the oven after the
first two games of the carolina bruins
series and i'm just like they're too
fast
where you know they're just beating us
the whole [ __ ] game we lose the first
game we lose the second game we go up to
boston
we're down one nothing in game three i'm
like are these [ __ ] [ __ ] gonna sweep
us
is this really gonna happen
and then all of a sudden we just been
turning it on every i can't even see
i've been turning her on but
we somehow won the next two games
because i'll tell you even like
this last one game four
i just felt like they had the puck for
the whole [ __ ] game and somehow huh
somehow we won four to two
i'll tell you though that [ __ ] last
goal that we had
where it's a set play where patrice
bergeron's taking the draw of course why
wouldn't he be the second the second
the ref drops the puck marshawn starts
breaking in behind bergeron because it's
it's it's patrice bergeron you know he's
going to win the draw and as he's
breaking in pasta is is getting right in
front of the goaltender on the other
side skating backwards
bergeron wins the draw
right back between his legs
marshawn picks it up curls around sends
it right across
before the defenseman can figure out
what's going on it's right on the tape
for pasta and then it's in the back of
the net it was a [ __ ] thing
of beauty and it's what you expect from
the perfection line
the perfection lines out that perfect
how many times are they gonna say that
during the broadcast jesus christ
i know that's what they call it but they
usually say that bruins with the top
line out there
you know
their first line their goal scores
they always say you know in the
newspaper they call it the perfection
light but during that broadcast
um they just kept saying the perfection
line it was kind of like driving me nuts
after a while i was just like dude i get
it i get it it's called the perfection
line what i don't get is what's going on
with my [ __ ] phone right now
i need to see that i'm still recording
am i still recording i am still
recording all right
so
anyways the bruins are somehow
two to two
um
with the hurricanes who appear to be
clearly
more talented and faster than we are
i was watching the game with my
father-in-law and we were down two to
one
and i was saying to him about halfway
through the second period it's like i
know it's two to one it doesn't feel
like two to one it feels like we're down
like
two three goals here
you know and then we did the cliche but
they're letting us hang around right
and then what was it was it de bruster
de bruss get the first one or the second
one i don't know what
i don't know what it was sort of a
whirlwind and also you know it was
mother's day happy mother's day belated
mother's day to all the mothers out
there
uh so my wife was uh hanging upstairs
watching her fun tv so i was downstairs
with the kid and my father kids and my
father-in-law
um
you know watching the game and then also
running around with them having a good
time
uh
we made some uh
mother's day cards
for mom
and then also you know it was great
you know it was fantastic was you know
my wife loves a brunch
you know
she loves getting dressed up going out
to go see the people and everything like
that you know me okay maybe you don't
know me maybe you think you know me
maybe i'm just so [ __ ] arrogant that
i'm just gonna say you know me i'm not a
i'm not into brunch
you know what i mean you get dressed up
it's hot out
you're sweaty there's like [ __ ] syrup
and eggs and it's the whole thing is
gross and you you want to sit outside or
inside
uh inside okay inside's gonna be a
17-hour wait but i can stick you
directly in the sun in six minutes
and then everybody in my life has
pigment so they all look to me and i
don't wanna you know because they know i
have a need to be liked i just go
yeah no that's fine it's fine i'll uh
you know
put on my hat you know what i mean
so then i'm sitting there in a suit
wearing like a baseball hat so i look
like the guy in hollywood who just got a
fresh pair of hair plugs
and he's waiting for him to grow in and
he doesn't have the confidence you know
what i mean
um
so
we ended up over we went to
a brunch and uh
yeah
we left and we ended up going
somewhere else where we could sit inside
and it was fantastic
that's my thing about brunch it's like
who doesn't love breakfast
you know
who doesn't love lunch who doesn't love
combining the two of them and just being
a fat american
you know
what is what is the lunch part for
though i guess that's for the the people
that go there that haven't had
that already had breakfast
you know there's always that person at
the brunch the one who already got the
workout in
just did a 5k and they need some [ __ ]
carbs
um and rather than just eating the carbs
they have to show up with the [ __ ]
numbers still written on their arm
from their 5k and that grease pencil
[Music]
you always see that number
right is your [ __ ] you know right as
you're taking a big bite out of like a
[ __ ] waffle or something
you know
um anyway so
but i actually was talking to my lovely
wife and i think she's finally coming
around
to understanding why i don't like going
to brunches
um
[Music]
i'm trying to remember the last brunch
that i went to where it wasn't
ridiculously hot it's just always
[ __ ] hot and you always end up
outside and i just don't want to eat i
just don't want to eat breakfast
sitting in the blazing sun i mean i
don't think that's you know does that
make me anti-social i don't think it
does
it somehow always gets framed that way
speaking of framed
the boston red sox my god
i'm still i'm having so much fun
watching them even though they just keep
losing it's like the [ __ ] bad news
bears we just lost we just got we just
got our asses kicked by a bunch of
[ __ ] god whipped
by a bunch of goddamn nerds we were
playing
the chicago white sox
okay
we lost two out of three to the [ __ ]
orioles we lost three straight
to the white sox we lost our sixth game
in overtime extra innings whatever you
call it we are all for six
all right and i know there's a lot you
know trevor story got booed when he went
oh for four or four strikeouts
people are getting down on them okay now
we could possibly be this bad but i
don't think we are
i actually think we're getting all the
disappointment out of the way right now
as i'm recording this we are in last
place
we're a half a game or a game behind the
[ __ ] orioles
which it always pains me to see how bad
that they've been for the better part of
[ __ ] 30 years
because they were uh an institution when
i was growing up
uh as were the pirates
those were winning franchises if you can
believe it but uh now that we're you
know the it's sort of the post-steroid
era
you know luxury tax
big-time free agents everybody bouncing
around
um they have not been able to keep up
and uh i gotta i gotta tell you man i
would love to see the orioles get good
again
just to hear that oh
o l e s i used to love that in 1979 i
think that guy passed away that crazy
[ __ ] yosemite sam looking guy used to
stand up on the dugout and get everybody
going and they had [ __ ] eddie murray
and doug de san
all of them i loved all those guys
um but anyway we're in [ __ ] last
place
but i feel like you know if sale comes
back
and is even 80 of what he was
that's huge we got a vauldy so we kind
of have a nice one-two punch there and
if we could just start getting some
walks and stop having the goddamn
opposing pitcher always
all relaxed on the mound with you know
no one on base
clean [ __ ] slate
you know
nobody taking a lead off a third in his
peripheral if he's a righty right
i think we can start getting some wins
so we'll see
we'll see i i hate to say this i do love
that the yankees are in first place
not cause i like the yankees
not because i like the yankees it's
because the blue jays were running their
[ __ ] beaks up there in toronto about
you know hey last year was the trailer
this year's the movie well let me tell
you something it's not performing too
well is it
580 i guess that's all right
you know what is the movie you almost
win the division i decided i'm just
going to give the blue jays [ __ ] all
all baseball season it'll be fun even
though i really like toronto and um i
was all ready to jump on the maple leafs
bandwagon when we were down o2
i was like all right this looks like if
we're lucky
five game series and then i'm just gonna
do what i do in the playoffs all the
time as i root for the toronto maple
leafs
because they haven't won since 1967 yet
they sell out every [ __ ] game and you
cannot get a ticket i mean
it's the greatest fan base in hockey i
mean who else name another fan base that
could get kicked in the dick
since lyndon johnson was in office and
it's they're still selling out it just
doesn't happen so you have to respect
that
um
anyway
and i'm happy for uh joe bartnick's
pittsburgh penguins i don't know what
they're doing today but i know they're
up 2-1
against the rangers i guess that wasn't
supposed to happen i have no idea all
right let's get on to some and the
celtics
lost a heartbreaker
you know
great first half bucks destroyed us in
the third and then we came back two
little too late in the fourth
but um
you know the celtics have showed that
they can play with them i mean both
teams are a little banged up but um
i don't know a lot less chirping
from my friends who are box fans that
were [ __ ] sitting there talking like
they were just going to come in and man
handle us
so but then again if we lose the next
one we'll be down 3-1 but i don't think
we're gonna i think we're gonna [ __ ]
steal one out there but at some point
you know
my math is correct we're gonna have to
win two in a row if we're gonna take
your series i'll tell you right now
um all right let's talk the la forum
i got to do a show there
um
and we put the stage in the middle we
did it in the round so it could be uh
you know so that way nobody's that far
away oh the lovely nia everybody hello
walking in i was just getting ready to
start talking about the la forum show
um
so i uh
before the um
before the show i was mentioning to you
guys that i was thinking about i don't
even think i told it to you
no i don't think i said that on thursday
podcast i ended up uh
calling up
my drum teacher and friend uh dave elich
and he's been way more of a friend in
the last year because i've been so busy
than a drum teacher because i haven't
had time to get over that i was just
telling him i saw you know one of these
one of these goddamn prodigy kids on
instagram
just doing some insane 30-second note
[ __ ] gospel chop phil and it was just
bugging me going
teach me one of those damn things
like how come i can't hear those things
how come it's just because i'm old
my brain's too slow
just never been able to rag and get up
to 16th note triplets then i just i get
tired you know after a certain tempo
it's just like what am i doing here
well i don't want to start buzz sawing
through all of this [ __ ] i mean it's
fun to do i guess if you can't do it but
whatever so i called him up
and i was trying to figure out when i
would have time and i just didn't have
time and then just hit me i was just
like well listen i'm down the forum
you know when you play the pace you rent
it and it's yours for the whole day
it's literally yours
so i go you know why don't we rent a
couple of drum kits set him up face to
face in the middle of that arena and
he's like you want you want to do let's
[ __ ] let's [ __ ] do that so he called
up a buddy of his
and and
you know i didn't know what kind of kits
you were going to get but i knew that
they were going to sound right
because elich tunes him up like nobody
i've ever heard right
and i showed up
and he had
the orange vistalite john bonham kit
and then he had the stainless steel one
and for zeppelin fans bought him after
he had he had the maple kit natural
finish then he went under the green
sparkle one that i think he took out on
the road for
the led zeppelin three tour and then
after that he loved that kit so much
that he didn't take it out on the road
and that was his studio kit right
through to the end of his life i believe
uh but his touring kit
was i'll get the door i'll get the door
all right
um his touring kit which that orange
vista light kit
um it's on the song remains the same
um concert video he played that kit
right through
i want to say 77
and then he switched to the stainless
steel kit so um
that's what we had facing each other in
the middle of an empty la forum
we had him mic'd up with wedges pointed
at us
and i have to tell you it was the most
insane [ __ ] sound
i've ever heard i gave some of the drum
footage to andrew he's gonna get that
edited together and i'm gonna post it i
know dave posted one of him just sort of
tuning up the drums messing around but i
have to be honest with you i've known
dave i don't know how long since like
2015 maybe
that's the most i've ever seen him
smiling
and laughing
at one point we were just playing a
groove and we were trading force
and
after like dave would be playing a fill
and would just be laughing at like this
how great it sounded it was so much
so much [ __ ] fun and um
and once again a great way
to kind of uh ease your nerves i think
when uh you got to do a gig that big is
to kind of go in there and just make a
whole bunch of noise before the show in
the thing
kind of get you know
the butterflies out i guess because uh
you know it's a big show so anyway so uh
we ended up playing for like an hour and
a half to the point you know i got a
little blister on my finger blissed on
my finger
you can tell i'm not taking lessons
lately because i was holding the sticks
the wrong way so i got a little blister
on my finger whatever but like
um
it was the fastest 90 minutes of my life
that's how amazing that was and uh
then we went back got something to eat
and then the crowd came in we stopped
playing at like 6 30 they opened the
doors at seven the crowd came in
and um
i was working with bianca christa uh veo
that was her first arena first time in
the round
and she went up and [ __ ] crushed it
and then brought up dean and dean just
took it to a whole other level and then
he brought me up
and uh
it was just awesome from the second i
got up there the [ __ ] crowd was just
awesome
thank god
and um
yeah i don't know it's weird
i actually there was one moment where i
took it in because you know at the end
of the day you got to go up people say
you got to go up you got to take it in
you got to take you never know when you
get you know you may not ever come here
again it's like i get it but i also have
to like [ __ ]
do the job here you know
i can't be standing up there
ah right but there was a moment about
three-quarters of the way through when i
at that point i was like all right i got
all my strongest bits left this is gonna
be a great show
you know basically uh
the other team pulled their goaltender
at that point right so i know i'm gonna
win essentially and uh i did look up at
the ceiling
and just sort of think for half a second
like i am in the [ __ ] l.a forum right
now
and uh anytime i go in there it is
impossible not to think of the showtime
lakers
and magic johnson and those iconic shots
of him when he was in the warm-up
jersey coming out of the um
um
coming out of the uh whatever the locker
room and they had that little flap on
the back up top
and it just said you know lakers and it
said johnson i think right across my i
don't think it said magic i think i said
johnson i was just thinking of that
thinking how kareem played there
were the
jamal wilkes
um
who else michael cooper
it's insane this was like 40 years ago
and i still remember so many of the
people on that team
it was jamal wilkes and then after him
was it norm nixon
i can't remember who else they had if i
had to try to name their starting five
it was kareem worthy
magic johnson
it was jamal wilkes in the early 80s and
he had that crazy release where he'd
bring the ball almost like around his
head
uh michael cooper
um
who was just tenacious on d
i mean i don't know how tall he was he
was like six seven six eight and i think
he weighed like 160 pounds and you would
think that he would get pushed all over
the court and he did the guy just had so
much heart
it's crazy how back then like how much
you hate those guys
you know in the moment when they're
playing
and then years later when you look back
you start to just because the games were
so great you start to love the people
you hated
as a sports fan
um
anyway so uh
yeah it was it was an insane night and i
just want to thank everybody netflix and
everybody for uh helping to put that
thing together
um
i did get to go up at the hollywood bowl
i came up if i told you that i got to do
15 in front of dave chappelle which is
amazing i was not there the night when
all that craziness happened
fortunately uh
nothing too nuts happened
so uh
you know whatever
whatever every once in a while some
lunatic
[Laughter]
there's always going to be some sort of
incident here or there i you know
i don't know
who knows i try not to talk about [ __ ]
like that because i notice all these
[ __ ] idiots you know they turn
everything you say into like click bait
like i literally talk will like speak in
this tone and they'll be like you know
bill burr
you know goes off
on guy at the hollywood bowl it's like i
i didn't i didn't
you're just saying that i did so anyway
um
those drums sounded so [ __ ] good i
haven't played at home yet
you know
even though i should i think i'm going
to go out there this afternoon but i
didn't even play at home since then
because
i'm trying to forget
how unbelievable it sounds i mean when i
post the videos even with me playing and
i play like [ __ ] just to warn you i
haven't played like two months so my my
kick drum foot was was sloppy
but um
on those vista lights and all of that
stuff in that empty arena it was
literally the bottom sound
um
it was [ __ ] insane and uh i was
sitting there going like man i would
love to get
i'd love to get a vista light kit i
really would i mean
john theodore made this sick sick
[ __ ] video
introducing the whole new line of them
and they have the those the swirl ones
the vista light swirl ones and one of
them is is like the uh blue and olive
badge
and clear i believe or might be what i
think it's clear yeah it's clear and for
me that's the [ __ ] one
um
my only knock they're just really bright
so that kind of like if you just want to
[ __ ] bash
like that is the goddamn kit i can tell
you that um
oh speaking of which dude was it me or
they kind of played a couple of sick ass
tunes during the bruins game
i mean it wasn't the usual why can't we
be friends after a fight you know those
hacky hockey songs like i think they got
somebody going guys we got to switch
this up in there
so they were playing you know some of
the modern mumble rap [ __ ] which is
great you got to do that for the young
kids
but then they played iggy pop
iggy pop and like some real [ __ ] too it
was just it was playing now i'm gonna be
a dog they're playing that i'm just like
what the [ __ ] well how does that
correlate
to uh
to what's going on in the ice right now
i was trying to think of the uh
the connection and then later on in the
game they played iron maiden the trooper
i was like i don't know who's the new dj
over there or who [ __ ] updated the
playlist but i thought it was a really
nice balance of some fresh old songs
and then whatever the kids are listening
to today i don't know i let kids weigh
in on that but i thought uh
i was very impressed with the goddamn dj
so here's my question to you
can the bruins
go down into carolina and steal one down
there because i think it's carolina
boston carolina
for the rest of this series um
you know we shall see
um
but hey you know what's awesome was when
we were trading fours i was it was it
sounded so [ __ ] amazing that for for
the first time ever i wasn't in my head
and um
as someone who's played drums forever
i've only done that a couple of times so
if you're a young drummer out there or
an old drummer like me if you ever get a
chance
to play with another drummer and just
start trading fours i can't even tell
you
or maybe just someone on another
instrument or something if you have
friends
that you can jam with you know what i
mean which gets harder when you get to
be my age and you're a dad and you got
kids and that type of stuff trying to
find another dad
that can sneak out
you know which is [ __ ] awesome
because you both immediately become like
[ __ ] 13 and 14 again
like hey man let's play some [ __ ]
priest man
um i i can't even begin to tell you like
i just personally how much i got out of
that and was just
i for like a few moments during say like
an hour and a half i felt like there was
a good like 27 seconds in there
where i felt the way i feel when i do
stand up where i'm not thinking
i'm just sort of doing it and just it's
just flowing out of me you know at least
on the good night so
um i've kind of been chasing that
um
for a while now and i actually saw a
little glimpse of it some
so basically what i'm saying is the
second i'm done with this podcast i'm
gonna go [ __ ]
gonna go uh gonna go play some drums um
so anyway
and lastly but not leastly
um
i i decided because i was so [ __ ]
busy
you know i'm gonna try this [ __ ]
intermittent
intermittent fasting
which is funny to me intermittent
fasting when i was a kid that was called
poverty
but now it's like an exercise or a diet
movement
intermittent fasting it used to be you
fasted because you didn't have any money
[Music]
you wouldn't eat from monday to like
thursday morning but it wasn't because
you wanted to it's because you didn't
have any [ __ ] money
um
or whatever now it's like
for people you know
privileged enough to have food every day
it's a choice
so it's like a 16-hour fast and you just
do it every day and you just sort of eat
like eight hours
you know you eat healthy whatever but
i've been going to the gym my [ __ ]
shoulder feels good
and uh
i don't know we're going to see if
that's going to work i know i'm like i
i'm kind of turning the corner here and
i'm trying all this new [ __ ] and the
biggest one ever is like you know how i
told you guys i went golfing
at atc golf tournament which was just a
[ __ ] the best time ever
i have been fighting
not playing again i think i caught the
bug i kind of had an awesome time and i
now get it i now get why people go over
and do that [ __ ] and uh
i think i'm gonna play with one of my uh
siblings soon
and ran to a buddy of mine
who lives up in canada and i think i'm
gonna get in early
and play around with him too
i don't know i don't know what happened
i will tell you this so what's funny to
me is how they always try to i mean
granted i'm not a member anywhere
um but it always cracks me up how they
try to make like golf courses where like
there's all these [ __ ] white guys
like illuminati people like carving up
the golf course i mean that's not the
golf golf course like carving up the
world
um
now i'm not saying this doesn't happen
but as far as my experience going to a
golf course it's just a bunch of guys
giving each other [ __ ]
that are [ __ ] excited that they got a
three hour window four hour window
and they don't have to deal with all of
their [ __ ] responsibilities because
at the end of the day
you know
men are basically we're just big kids
i don't think
we necessarily ever grow up and um the
level of [ __ ] [ __ ] talking that's all
it was
the entire time i was on there i like
[ __ ] really
really enjoyed it so um
i don't know we shall see we'll we'll
see if i if i actually give into this
thing but i feel like i have enough
i got enough [ __ ] hobbies or whatever
but um i i i'll come i've come this far
that i i can say i get why people do it
um all right with that
let's do a little um
let's do some advertising here oh look
who it is everybody indochino
all right these guys make custom suits
for only 3.99 uh choose every detail on
a suit shirt dinner jacket you got any
smoking jackets and more at affordable
prices that may surprise you for fully
customized pieces every suit is made to
your exact measurements and you can
customize every detail create a suit
that fits you and your style why
wouldn't you do this i always thought it
was so cool when conor mcgregor was
was promoting his fights
how he would have custom tailored suits
you know now granted
we all don't have conor mcgregor money
right we all can't go in to the ring
with mayweather and everybody's gonna
tune in to watch it
right so indochino this is this is this
is the common man's conor mcgregor suit
here create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly with options for
fabrics lapel shape custom monograms
statement linings and more the best part
indochino suits start from just 429
and shirts from 79
indochino offers a completely custom
fitted shirts casual wear and more get a
wardrobe personalized to your style and
taste without spending a fortune
they're always adding new pieces and
options so you can stay on trend and in
style explore their relaxed yet refined
approach to spring suits with their new
spring
pastels
um
if you've got a big day coming up
getting the perfect look is no big deal
with indochino get 50 off any purchase
at of 3.99 or more by using your promo
code bur at indochino.com that's 50 off
a purchase of 3.99 or more at ind wait
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code burr
uh you know what i just keep dropping
weight here and i get myself down to my
fighting weight
um to quote bob pogo from f is for
family my fighting weight um
i'm gonna order one of these suits
maybe wear it
do some stand-up gigs you know what i
mean open collar
right
coming in there
wearing a watch as big as my ego be that
guy all right butcher box everyone
butcher box is a subscription service
that takes the guesswork
out of getting quality meats like a
hundred percent grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken and
wild-caught seafood you don't know what
they're gonna do
and right and more right to your
doorstep now listen if you wanna drop
some weight you know you got to be
fueling your body with the right thing
little intermittent fasting a little
[ __ ] butcher box and next thing you
know you get into indochino suit you see
what i'm doing here
are you smelling what this bald orange
male is cooking
uh every month butcherbox ships a
curated selection of high quality meat
right to your home free shipping
for the continental u.s no antibiotics
or added hormones packed fresh and
shipped frozen for con for convenience
so you can save time on your next
grocery store trip customize your own
box or go with one of theirs either way
you can get exactly what you want um
i've been using these guys forever by
the way i got to tell you something
they're uh
they're heritage bred pork is uh one of
the best pork chops i've ever had get
free ground beef for life everybody and
save up to 180 a year now by signing up
through may 15th
all right if you sign up now you'll get
two pounds of their member favorite
ground beef for free
with every order
for the life of your membership people
90 of the world i don't know if it's 90
but a lot of the world is starving these
guys are giving away beef
uh now through may 15th is your last
chance to get free ground beef for life
from butcher block box
sign up at
butcherbox.com get two pounds of ground
beef for free in every order for the
life of your membership subscribe at
butcherbox.com
to claim this offer now
all right with that
let's get into the uh little sip of
water here
oh they need water
um
f1
oh somebody's gonna talk formula one hey
when the [ __ ] did they add a race in
miami and by the way
congratulations to f1 talk about picking
the perfect
u.s city for a formula one race
you know you got to have it's got to be
a destination city it's got to be a
[ __ ] sexy city there's got to be
beautiful people there there's got to be
yachts there's got to be sunshine
okay there's got to be that whole
[ __ ] um
what do they call that uh excess vibe to
it
all right
that is miami you know i know there's
low-key areas of miami but i don't know
when you blow through that city you
don't seem to run into them all right f1
everybody
uh bill it seems like all of a sudden f1
racing was more relevant
in the u.s i thought it was just you
talking about it
um that put it on my radar but but then
there was the netflix show and more
races here then i just saw this tweet
and i thought you might find it
interesting formula one was acquired by
liberty media liberty liberty liberty
liberty liberty media for
4.4 billion in 2016 and it's now one of
the fastest growing sports globally
they're up
they're up billions of dollars on the
investment already and it's one of the
best
case studies in business
um
well i'll tell you what has made it even
better too is now it's competitive i
haven't watched the miami race yet
i'm going to try to watch that tonight
when uh
you know we're doing a uh
it's the end of the netflix
this unbelievable festival that they put
together and um
tonight's the last night and all the
comics will be hanging down the comedy
store so i'm going down there so after
that i'm gonna watch the race uh hoping
that ferrari
and uh red bull both have great races
and then also hoping that lewis hamilton
and mercedes
you know get their act together which i
know they're going to because i'm seeing
like a three-way
battle and the best f1 season since i
started watching in 2015
which that was a great one even though
it was mercedes and mercedes was just
watching those two guys like in days of
thunder was a nico rosberg
and lewis hamilton was [ __ ] awesome
to see
um
all right
so
there's one in miami and there's now now
we have two races we have one in miami
and we have one in austin texas and then
there's also one up in montreal
so in north america and then you get the
one in mexico
so in north america you got four races
that's pretty [ __ ] cool um
and you know what there's gonna be some
lunatic with the [ __ ] private jet
that's gonna go to all four on this side
of
this side of the world and north of the
equator
um
i've been to the one in uh
montreal that's it but my next one i
want to go to the one in mexico city the
one that goes through the uh the minor
league ballpark i think that's [ __ ]
cool as [ __ ]
um all right dr banner
uh hey bill you mentioned the hulk by
his real name dr david banner
um
in the comics his name is bruce banner
but for the television show they changed
it to david because they thought bruce
was a gay name
seriously really bruce banner
david banner
well you know bruce you can kind of say
it that way bruce banner
david banner you can do that to anything
with that accent
bill burr
oh isn't that look at the alliteration
you can make anything sound a little gay
i think bruce is you know
bruce springsteen
bruce bruce
bruce banner i stand by bruce
um
and if they thought it was a little gay
then they should have kept it
because then he got a nice duality right
then he turns into this [ __ ] raging
aggro
then the hulk could be like maybe he's
like one of these
alpha guys that's pretending he's
straight but he's fighting the fact that
he's gay maybe that's why he's actually
angry
you know and is that why he fought
batman i was superman
maybe the hulk is jealous of superman
and batman's you know relationship
you know he just feels like the side
piece i'm sorry uh it was
anyway it broke from the alternative
name
which was a big thing with stan lee
peter parker
reed richards mr fantastic sue storm
reed's wife the invisible woman
stephen strange etc
oh all the all
what is it it broke from the all
hey what's up
i'm doing my podcast buddy
what's the matter
[Music]
all right hang on a second
all right i'm back i'm back um
yeah so he said all
it's a-l-l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i-v-e
all
alliterative
i've never seen that word in my life you
mean alliteration
oh a litter a liter i can't say it
alliterative
i gotta look that up and figure out how
to say it
a literal a-l-l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i-v
pronunciation i gotta hear how do you
say this
alliterative
alliterative
well there's your [ __ ] five dollar
word for the day alliterative all
alliterative names hey you know what
shout out to this man or woman who wrote
this
this email
alliterative
all it broke from the all
they broke from the alliterative names
which was a big thing with stan lee
peter parker reed richard sue storm
stephen strange bruce banner
dr david banner well they kind of had dr
david
um
that's two d's in a row
you know
what does dick start with d
so how come that's not still like
homoerotic
you know i mean that's basically it i
mean the entire superhero thing
you know like it or not i mean it does
look like
a bit of a drag show does it not um
[Music]
i'm campaigning for a gay hulk
um anyways righteous
oh my god then somebody tries to beat
him up in a rest area and he beats the
[ __ ] out of him that'd be [ __ ]
amazing all right righteous [ __ ] segment
hey billy bathtub
on the topic of people getting caught
lying and being [ __ ] while coming off
as good people
uh
someone i went oh i love that that's
that's that's one of my uh my favorite
things to do as a person
i'm amazing hey bill what about when you
did this oh i don't recall that
someone i went to high school with who
spent the last five plus years reporting
on the dumbest members of the political
party he opposes
uh it's a lot of look at
what this person
who doesn't matter said you should hate
everyone who doesn't think like us type
of [ __ ]
he published people's personal
information online who know
some of which ultimately turned out to
have no
some of which ultimately turned out to
have no affiliation with the thing he
was reporting on anyway
a bunch of s's to make fun of me
this [ __ ] just got caught on camera
camera vandalizing places of worship
for minority groups i have no idea why
but maybe he was going for one of those
things where people start a fire just so
they can be the hero that re reports it
sort of deal i have no idea when the
trial is but i'm thinking about flying
in for it
did i mention this person once accused
me of stealing his math book from his
locker
because it was easier than saying he
left it at home i never forgot that [ __ ]
these people wait a minute who is this
guy
who he must have so much power that you
don't want to say his name or
her name it can't be or her it doesn't
fit the narrative
yeah that's why um
i try to make sure that when i do my
stand-up act i stay in the i'm just a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like
because i don't think anybody can sit
there and start going you know what you
know what your problem is
you know before it eventually comes back
and bites you in the ass like well hey
didn't you do this this and this
and doesn't that contradict everything
that you just said well yeah it does so
sorry
all right relationship
vulnerability
uh greetings from greece oh god i'm
gonna do a show there someday
i swear to god i am greetings from
greece dear bill burr sorry in advance
but it gets sad
because it gets sad but i'm really
troubled oh jesus some background
i'm a 24 year old guy
who's been surrounded with funerals for
the last seven years
one of those funerals was my best friend
uh who was murdered when i was 17. oh
man sorry to hear that since then and up
until my 20s i really struggled keeping
a smile on my face or having any
motivation in life
because of that i lost many
relationships and friends due to not
being always emotionally available or
present as days went i finally got up on
my feet
and started accepting our mortality at
least i thought so here's my problem
um
i'm in a happy three-year relationship
which had no issues lately though things
are getting weird my depressive past is
catching up on me
as i didn't resolve the sadness like i
thought but i had just closed the lid
as a legend once said
um yeah that doesn't work
that doesn't work you should be uh all
right i already think i know what my
vice view is gonna be
you know as a non-professional
um all right
this with the combination of my
girlfriend's sudden change of routine
she found her first job where i don't
see her that often really startled me i
get these huge waves of sadness and
loneliness accompanied with the
insecurities i never had yeah probably
her suddenly leaving having to leave for
work reminding you how your friend
suddenly wasn't there anymore
this is becoming an issue since i'm
really into communicating feelings slash
problems with my lady but this time it
feels weird i seem
parentheses and am emotionally weak
vulnerable and insecure literally the
top three things a woman don't want you
to be
um
yeah well that's the oh that's the top
three things the other person in the
conversation doesn't want to
deal with
on a daily basis because it's a lot
so and that's what you have therapists
for
is they can actually
take that on and if you go into a
therapist i think it eases the tension
in your relationship because
um
you're talking to a professional so you
start moving in the right direction
and then when you talk to your
significant other they know that you're
working on yourself and then you're not
just dumping your day on them which can
be exhausting
anyway um it's not the first time i
experienced these feelings but i always
could manage to put a happy face put on
a happy face and say
that everything is all right doesn't
seem to be the case this time
it's not a job to fix me nor wait for me
i wasn't like this 99 relationship i was
the happy funny dude who she could
always count on now i just feel like a
man child what do i do i've talked about
it she tries to understand and support
me but i can't stop having the
unavoidable feeling of the pressure that
if i don't get my [ __ ] straight fast i
may lose her
um
thank you for making my car ride
something to look forward to with your
podcast all the best to you and your
family can't wait for your next special
english is my third language sorry for
any trouble it may cause you humble brag
um
all right dude you speak three languages
all right you're a funny dude you got a
great girlfriend okay just go get some
therapy
and stop worrying about losing her
all right if she takes off that's her
[ __ ] issue
it's not your issue um
and if she takes off that'll be sad you
go through that sadness and eventually
the right one comes along and they don't
leave
all right and if she's the right one she
won't leave but right now if i was you
just work on yourself
and um
you know talk that [ __ ] out cry it out
do whatever you got to do you know
there's a lot of stuff out there about
mushroom therapy uh looking at i've
never done that but um
you know
i've i've heard a lot of good things
about that it's good for ptsd
and trying to work your [ __ ] out so you
actually get to
live a happy life because
why should you be miserable
because of that horrible thing somebody
else did to your friend
and that's the thing about when somebody
does something like that it doesn't just
obviously affect the person
that they attacked it's it's the ripple
effect and it can literally affect how
you are in a relationship how you're
going to be as a father and a husband
and then for generations people deal
with these
these issues
um it's sort of the the blowback
or whatever um
of whatever happened so i hope you're
able to work through that [ __ ] and as
always go to a professional
not a [ __ ] jerk off with the podcast
but you know i appreciate your writing
not that i was giving you [ __ ] all right
okay so don't don't [ __ ] get down in
the dumps because of what i just said
there all right
jesus
hope i didn't snip the wrong wire there
at the end i feel like was in an action
movie all right
what do we got here oh new segment idea
old people remedies that work
oh i like that
hey bill my grandmother an immigrant
from spain obvious
immediately has credibility
anybody whose grandparents are from the
quote old country just meaning not this
country you always feel like they got
some information
you know
um
she makes a rutabaga soup
my grandmother an immigrant from spain
has some crazy remedies
and
a lot of them work little things like
eat this if your stomach hurts or do
this if you have a headache the one
that's can you tell me both of those
that'd be amazing the one that sticks
out that has worked for me a million
times is a midday facial face wash
she would always say tell us to wash our
face in the middle of the day because it
gave gave us a second morning and more
pep in our step or something i thought
it was stupid as a kid but i do it all
the time
i get crushingly tired at 2 p.m it's not
for lack of eating right or exercise
it's more so my job
and being at or near my desk i'll just
go to the bathroom at work and splash
water on my face and on my neck work
still sucks but i certainly feel better
do you have any i think your listeners
would probably
have some too
oh
wow
do i have any old school remedies
look i'm german irish we just sit there
and take it whatever's happening to us
um i would love to hear your remedies i
can't tell you like for some
physical [ __ ]
um
you know having dealt with frozen
shoulder and my right and left arms i am
now obsessed
with keeping my my
shoulders free from uh
you know
like
getting all bound up and i think
everybody to a certain extent
has frozen shoulders
like uh
you just don't notice it because you
have like 85 percent mobility or
whatever but like
i can on one side
let's see if i can still do it my left
arm i can put behind my back
and then with my right arm i can reach
back grab the fingers
and uh pull my left arm up my right arm
i can't quite do that i can only touch
the tips and i've been working on that
and i just do like a set of ten
of trying to bring my arm as high up
between my shoulder blades my hand
basically as i can i do a set of 10 of
those and then on the 10th one i take my
other hand behind my back and i just
sort of push my arm up
a little bit more and it's it's a weird
pain that frozen shoulder kind of pain
and it's just schmutz and like your
tendons and stuff so
um
i've kind of gotten into that and then
um andrew themilis the great andrew
demilis on this podcast
showed me these
the [ __ ] they're called himalayan squats
hindu squats i don't want the hindu
squats
that i'm actually going to start doing
today that are supposed to be really
good for you and actually good for
longevity and life but as far as like
um
i think a lot of the remedies are more
on my wife's side you know i'll get you
guys on the next podcast i'll give you
like a uh if you're starting to get sick
um
one of those [ __ ] things you make on
the stovetop that has all these
different spices and [ __ ] and you just
drink it down and
it's got the cayenne pepper in it and
all that i think everybody has a version
of that but i'll be honest with you i
don't have a lot of those things but i
love that a lot of people do
which i would find the only thing that i
know
that i've learned that helped sell your
stomach after a big
meal was when i was in italy they had
like these you know they were called
aperitifs or liqueurs or whatever and it
made no [ __ ] sense because you'd be
so stuffed and be like i don't want
anything else and you would just do a
little shot it was like really sweet
liquor
and it just [ __ ] settled your stomach
like uh
you couldn't believe i'll give you one
here's one a lot of people don't know if
you rent cars all the time
you're pulling into a gas station you're
like oh what side is the gas tank on
you guys these are like sort of life
hacks what size is the gas tank on in
every car
if you look at the fuel gauge there'll
be a little gas tank and then there's an
arrow that points to which side the tank
is on
i didn't know that for the first 35
years of my life and matt frost
over at caa give him a shout out
he's the guy that [ __ ] told me about
that in like
the early 2000s and at that point i was
doing college gigs almost every weekend
and i like had memorized where because i
always got the dodge neon because back
then i was with national rental car and
they always had like a purple dodge neon
i would always end up with one of those
things and um
driving through like kansas or [ __ ]
south dakota and i i always forget what
side the [ __ ] thing was on and i was
telling that i was
saying that telling him that story one
day and he said you know i just learned
this the other day so there you go i
give you a life hack i can't give you
any sort of [ __ ]
um
remedy or whatever
i'll tell you the one that everybody
wants to know is when you get a [ __ ]
cold how the hell you get rid of it
um all right or how you make it you stop
it from coming on
um all right that is the podcast
everybody um
i'm still in the edit room and um
this week i believe i'm up in like
sacramento
i'm playing the oracle
where uh the warriors used to play
and then i'm playing the cow palace
where every [ __ ] major
band i ever loved played
van halen all of those guys right on
through all the 80s so that's going to
be a huge one and um
i don't know this is the biggest tour i
ever did and i'm blown away that all of
these people are showing up so i'm
really working hard on my act
and i want to make sure it's going to be
worth your money so thank you guys for
uh you know coming to my shows all these
years all right
so
that is the uh that is the podcast and i
will talk to you uh i'll check in on you
on thursday
go bruins go celtics and i'm hanging in
there with the red sox i think they're
going to turn it around with chris sale
comes back all right